[Music]
today we're gonna talk about isolated
Queen fun positions your favorite topic
okay and isolated Queen point means your
queen pond is isolated class just know
now most people don't like isolated
ponds because they're dogmatic and they
blunder a lot but I'm gonna show you
positions where it's good to have
isolated pawn and positions where it's
not so good the first few games are mine
and the last game is my favorite a game
between two players you've never heard
of Karpov and Kasparov okay I'm not
kidding okay so the first game was
played by me and this was a nimzo-indian
and normally an isolated Queen pond
openings openings in positions that have
isolated Queen ponds normally it's a
queen pawn opening if white plays d4 I
move one it's less likely but still
possible okay and I've had this kind of
position quite often and black plays d5
if black doesn't play d5 ever when the
game wouldn't be in my lecture because
there would be an isolated Queen pond
okay so d5 and eventually I was able to
take this pawn and my opponent realized
if he took with a night that this pawn
would be hanging on g7 so after trading
Queens he took with the pawn and we
start our lecture so this is an isolated
pawn and isolated means no pawn can
protect it
there's no point on adjacent files so
normally when you're looking at isolated
pawn you might be thinking I can win
that pawn I'll attack it and they can't
defend it and that's possible the other
way to play gets legislated want is to
play around it and block it so I can't
move and in this particular position I
have a dark squared Bishop which is in
front of the point it's actually more
light
Klee that we're gonna put a night in
front of a pawn when your opponent has
an isolated pawn you generally want a
knight in front of it because the knight
can't be attacked bishops could usually
be traded by other bishops in this
situation that's not possible because he
doesn't have a dark squared Bishop only
I do so my bishop in front of the pawn
is quite good I'm not interested in
winning the pawn I'm interested in it
never moving and attacking me so I
develop my pieces like I'm supposed to
and he decides to sacrifice a pawn and
the reason is he thinks he's going to
win my pawn on g2 because he has sort of
a skewer going Bishop e5 and he plays
Kiki 7 he's sort of giving up
why didn't he play Knight takes bishop
it's a brilliant tactical point this is
a beginner class anymore no no it's
illegal you can't do it as pinned now he
realized in fact we're gonna see another
game where I do the same thing he
realized if he takes my pawn what will I
do I'll give you a hint it's why I
played Bishop e5 you Bishop to g3 and
his rook isn't so healthy I might play
King f1 and take it
also his work can't move anywhere so
it's not healthy anyway and he changed
his mind decided his rook would get
trapped and he just unpinned his knight
with King e7 now he is threatening
Knight takes my bishop
so Bishop g3 and I'm a pawn up and well
now he has a lot of isolated pawns okay
that's three plated pawns
I have no isolated pawns my pawns are
all together so by blocking his pawn he
got desperate tried to get counter play
by getting his Knight to e4 and we're
going to see other games this lecture
we're using that d5 pawn or F White has
an isolate upon d4 it's actually great
for putting a knight on e4 that's
actually one of the benefits of having
an isolated pawn it controls the the
center
and white doesn't have any pawns
controlling black side of the center
this pawn here controls two white
squares in the center and white can't
say that he's doing that so black took
advantage of that but unfortunately he
lost upon doing it and the rest was a
bit silly and now I attacked the pawn
hooray and he doesn't want me to take it
does that Forks his King in the rook
how did black defend his d5 pawn I think
there's only one way to do it think yeah
I think there's only one way to do it
yep so it's isolated I blocked it and
now I'm attacking it Knight f6 I think
he played Knight f6 right and I want to
take his pawn but he defended it that's
not fair so how do you remove the
defender the knight on f6 then I could
take his pawn in the corner I think I
did that yeah okay now he made a move
you will not consider and he wanted home
come on you can do it
yes incorrect because you considered it
so it's wrong automatically yeah now he
made the best move
seriously yeah there were no homos he
resigned yeah because he's down upon his
Knights pin I'm threatening Knight takes
pawn after Bishop e6 I have several ways
to win rook c7 check Knight h5 or not
moving also winning because this pin is
really hard to break yeah so that was a
terrible game from his point of view and
his phone was weak the whole game and
putting the knight back on f6 that
really showed that 94 was misguided too
aggressive too quick instead of giving
up his pawn on g7 he should have
defended it or not played for it ie 4
but here he already has a bad position
the advantage of this pawn is you get to
play 94 you knights protected but
unfortunately he lost other material and
then his pawn was weak because his
knight wasn't defending it eventually he
went back so terrible game for my
opponent you might think boy what a bad
player but he was over 2,300 was okay
next game was against international
master Leonid Bhasin and this actually
came out of a transposition of a French
defense and I play d4 that's not easy to
do usually the French defense starts
efore you agree he played he 6 so I play
d4 ok and I like to play the exchange
variation because I figure this is a
symmetrical position that's my move
sounds good ok and usually we don't see
isolated Queen pawns here unless I have
them I'll take either side and I played
c4 now in fact in the world open in 2002
as you all know in Philadelphia I played
this position I offered my opponent a
draw he accepted and I got a grandmaster
norm ray and that was against Arthur
Yusupov who is a candidate for the World
Championship about 20 years ago although
not now
and when Alfred Roy put his head down
for 15 minutes and then he woke up and
said ok couldn't believe you draw a
player of my caliber
but okay now this is actually quite
humorous not the bone the the joke yeah
nobody got that okay so yeah I know you
claim you got it but you didn't okay so
a friend of mine a friend yeah he said
then whenever my point plays the French
I lose everything so I played the French
get some every game when I cry no that's
not what happened so I said what do you
mean he says well my puns get in the
center and my opponent takes them every
time I said okay I'll take care of it
play the exchange variation you've
already saved one pawn
can't lose the point you traded okay and
then play this variation your opponent
won't know it now a lot of people when
they play the French with black and
white plays Bishop to d3 they were
taught to trade off these bishops by
playing ninety seven and Bishop f5 which
is usually a good idea not a good idea
in this variation c4 and I've had many
people in blitz chess play 97 okay and I
told the guy if they play 97 you have a
really good move here who can find it
really good move for white highly
recommended anybody but him okay there
was a USCF election once for you know
policy board and for one position there
was one guy running and they were
reading the votes out so they said his
name odd and then one of the votes was
anybody but him okay I know who cast
that vote - it wasn't me that should've
him so anybody with you you see five and
my friend is rated about 1950 and I said
oh then you win a piece the bishops
trapped and his answer was nobody will
ever do that you're crazy and so forth
okay
maybe that's another time we were
talking now and the first game after our
talk next week he got this position his
opponent resigned so I think I was right
okay then he started playing this
against the friends because he wanted
even if I knew him without thinking okay
now my opponents international master so
for some reason
didn't play 97 losing a piece
unfortunate okay he took on c4 and I
took and actually this could be from a
Queens gambit accepted notice I have an
isolated pawn who would have thunk it
but that's the lecturer so okay and I
played h3 because I thought Bishop g4
would be annoying so h3 and he played h6
because he thought Bishop g5 would be
annoying and I played Bishop to e3
because I developed my pieces Bishop to
h5 f5 I should say at night h4 now nine
h4 attacks his bishop I crossed my
fingers but he saw it but I didn't play
nine h4 to win his bishop because that
wouldn't be fair I actually want to play
Knight f5 but I gotta get my Knight to
f5 so I'm going to put my Queen on f3
and then play Knight f5 occasionally if
his bishop goes back I could sometimes
play Knight to g6 and he's pinned now
this point is isolated that's the
lecture but it controls the e5 square
and the c5 square so that's not so bad
Bishop back Queen f3 so I have a very
active position and he can't arrest my
Queen with Knight to e5 because of my
isolated pawn and I have more pawns in
the center than my opponent well it's
isolated but I defended it and unlike
the previous game why played against the
isolated pawn I'm actually controlling
the square in front of my pawn I got
three guys here that are controlling the
square in front he can't block my pawn I
got that under control he can't win my
pawn I got that under control and now I
can go to f5 with my knight he played
Knight to d5 that's right okay and now
he's unleashed she can attack on the
knight on h4 a very suspicious move okay
notice how he's attacking my knight so
he wants to block my isolated pawn so
much
he moves to a square attack three times
that's why he's an IM and I'm and I'm
wait a minute okay so I played Knight f5
because I wanted to and we trade it and
now I have the two bishops and if he
eliminates my two bishops my palm will
no longer be isolated and all have a big
attack on the F file if he plays Knight
takes c3 F take c3 that I have a big
attack and I have two pawns in the
center to zero my bishop on e3 not so
good I can't really move anywhere so
yeah take my bishop get rid of it he
attacks my queen but I saw it attacked
my queen again I saw it again and now he
made the losing move which is good
because I was playing him if he was my
student then not so good nine to g6 the
same blunder my last opponent made maybe
you should learn this because my
opponents do it every game he thought
like my last opponent if I take the
b-pawn it'll take my be pawn just like
the last guy and then you suggested
right you said dr. Bishop to g3 but now
you suggest Bishop to b3 the rooks get
trapped on both sides of the board that
rooks not very good because I'm going to
take it okay so this position law is
actually already bad for black because
my D pawn is defended he'll never win it
it defends the center squares and I'm
controlling the square in front of it
and I have two bishops so already it's
better for Wyatt also I have sort of a
mild threat maybe more than a mild I'm
threatening Bishop takes h6 and the pawn
is defending everything can't do both so
I'm threatening h6
I'm threatening b7 he's already in
trouble why I have active pieces my
pieces are more active in his and mainly
it's because of my isolated pawn the D
pawn that's controlling squares of the
center I get to go to those squares my
pawns controlling c5 he's not
controlling c4 I'm controlling a5 and e4
and e5 I dominate the center and I have
to
Bishop's so he's already has a lost
position attacked my queen but I play
queen bee seven what's the threat yes
Bishop takes f7 and then I take his rook
with my queen if you somehow stops there
maybe I'll take his a7 pawn who knows
Queen b8 we traded and I attacked his
rook good luck saving York well that's
not your rook so I'm not you four and he
got all he could for his rook but look
at my isolated pawn defending my knight
yes okay look it is isolated pawns I'm
gonna take them okay that's better
yummy okay my isolated pawn could never
be captured and it actually protects
some important squares and okay then I
had technique because I was younger so I
actually played okay then king g6 what
kind of move is that and he resigned
here because we're gonna trade rooks and
then I'm gonna take that pawn and then
I'm gonna have an isolated Queen
okay isolated e pawn becomes a queen and
his line on h4 smells like ammonia to me
there's an ammonium I never know you
know an h4 you guys right in from there
and tell me what it is okay so yeah
terrible play from black but here the
isolated pawn worked out really well
because I had it and I gotta tell you
most people I know don't want to have
isolated deep pawn they hate it okay
I'll play either side and there's
advantages and disadvantages your deep
pawn can control a lot of squares and
sometimes your knight gets to go to e5
because your pawn is defending him and
it can be bad because your opponent
blocks it and takes it so if you know
what's good and what's bad about it then
you could take advantage of these things
okay this is one of my favorite games
it's against Al Cho who's a senior
master while he was in Chicago and we
played a very unusual opening he played
a very early c5 and when
you see all these pawns in the center
like this somebody's gonna have an
isolated pawn very likely turned out it
was him
tanks tanks total confusion okay and I
threw in a check if I remember correctly
yeah
and he doesn't really have a good way to
block because when he blocks he's gonna
block his Queen from access to the D
pawn so he's gonna have an isolated pawn
here
my Knights hanging so I took and as you
can see pretty quickly he has an
isolated pawn I already have it blocked
it's already blocked okay now I tried to
figure out where my pieces should go I
played Bishop d2 I wanted to play Bishop
c3 and B on this diagonal and cement my
knight on d4 so it's blocking his pawn
and I played Knight to b3 so my queen
would have excess towards his King and
he made a terrible move here Bishop to
d7 the bishop is very bad on d7 because
it blocks his Queen it blocks his
defense of the pawn and it forces my
Queens to a better Square this is the
typical move of a low-rated player not
of a strong player like Chau not having
a good day
my Queens not very good on a4 I'd like
to move it over to the Kings side and
his bishop was actually worse on d7 than
on CA it just blocks his Queen and he
defended and you can see black has an
isolated pawn but he has all the
negative aspects of the pawn he can't
play 94 because it's defended I have his
pawn blocked by four different pieces so
if he ever plays d4 I have a wide choice
of how to take his pawn so his pawn
can't move and he's not using the
squares that the pawn is defending for
attack on the other hand I have an
attack and here he blundered by playing
Bishop e5 because he thought this was a
good Bishop that's a bad Bishop let's
trade them
normally that would be correct but it's
incorrect here because black gives up a
very important square which I used to
squish him when black trades the bishops
with Bishop to b5 which square is he
giving away to me only Alex mother knows
see
so black just played Bishop b5 question
mark totally seating a very important
square to me yes f5 ok I want to put
pieces on f5 and crush him now for those
of you who showed up late show up
earlier next time ok this is a lecture
on isolated queen pawn positions ok so
my opponent thought he was trading
bishops but instead he was getting mated
so he was sort of right so we traded I
detect his queen he saw it and I played
Knight f5 now when your opponent plays
Knight f5 it's good to get rid of it
Bishop takes Knight Knight takes Knight
pawn takes Knight but yeah he can't get
rid of it so resigning was best because
he didn't resign then you're gonna see
what happened to him it wasn't pretty
now if it was White's move here white
has several moves that win well I think
F actually immediately Queen g5 wins
Knight takes g7 wins and positionally
Knight takes bishop and Bishop takes
Knight wins because he'll have 37
isolated pawns and doubled okay although
I wouldn't do that I would made him okay
so he played a pretty poor move I mean
it's probably the best move but it looks
terrible
98 defending now I can't mess up his
pawn structure but again this is all the
negatives of the isolated pawn the pawn
controls these squares but that's
useless
sometimes the pawn can advance and crush
you
it can never advance so it's just weak
and I have a big attack if the pawn
wasn't isolated and it was on e6 my
knight could never go to f5 so having an
isolated pawn is double-edged sometimes
it's good sometimes it's bad and I don't
I don't purchase
we prefer one side or the other I just
try to get advantage of what the
position offers me and I play queen G
for threatening everything every move
wins but the mean threat is 9 to h6
check and then I take his queen with
advantage and he'll stop that because
he's a good player and then I have a lot
of guys attacking his g7 pawn okay so
really strong players like Alex Marlar
when they see this position they go man
this isn't good for black they're like
ah and the better you get at chest the
more you hate blacks position so if you
think black is better you're one of the
lower rated players if you think black
is completely losing then you're better
than Carlsen much better okay somehow my
opponent played Queen e6 because he's
tricky now most people would just take
on g7 without thinking right Julian so
you didn't read his lines beforehand but
I was like wait a minute why is he
letting me take on g7 what's going on
here well night chase g7 hangs my queen
he plays Queen takes Queen Queen today's
g7 hangs my queen to his knight
so the obvious move his Bishop takes g7
now if he plays Knight takes bishop I
play Queen takes Knight mate otherwise I
start taking everything but when I
played Bishop g7 I saw the best move for
him and I was ready for it and when I
show my students this move they usually
think for a while and blunder all their
pieces and they lose so not good so what
did black play in this position what's
the best defense Alex h5 a sneaky move
attacking my Queen that's not nice and I
saw h5 and I saw the winning way to play
for white although most of my students
don't and they give all their pieces
away and black wins so that's not good
h5 is a very aggressive move it attacks
the Queen and it tries to draw the Queen
away from the bishop the Queen is
defending the bishop so if the Queen
takes the pawn that it's not defending
the bishop so why I can just take
if the Queen moves somewhere else maybe
the Knights hanging so the Queen's are
actually doing a lot defending the
knight defending the bishop but I saw
age fight I was ready for that who can
find the winning move for white somehow
my opponent start with one isolated pawn
they always you have three hmm remember
that because of my lecture yesterday
there were 5 isolated pawns true story
there doubled so White's a play and win
the crowd is deathly ill silent I wonder
they won't sue me for that right yes
Queen takes h5
he would play Knight takes g7 are we
continuing the analysis are we starting
over what we're starting over
Knights a c7 is what I played check and
if he doesn't take my knight and plays
King h7 which I don't understand I would
take his queen then take his rook so I
took my knight and now what did I do all
my pieces are attacked No
Bishop f6 does win but I played the
simpler Bishop takes rook check if he
takes my queen I take his queen and I
have an extra ruck although he
straighten his plunge down a little
still has an isolated deep line so he
took took and played on several more
moves instead of resigning much to
Alex's chagrin but ok that wasn't so
interesting ok and he resigned here now
I have an isolated D pawn so he resigned
he's like ok I got nothing now so in
that game ice lady pond looked terrible
he got enough to know now the most
famous isolated queen pawn game which
everybody knows right Alex is the carpa
a for mentioned Karpov Kasparov game
this is the famous car popke small white
square Symphony game game and I like
this game for a couple reasons I always
like when car Bob he's Gaspar you gotta
like that but more importantly Kasparov
has an isolated queen pawn then he
doesn't then he does again very
suspicious ok and Kasparov played Queens
gambit declined and Queen c2z move Queen
d2 zoom move rook c1 does it move Queen
b3 is a move rich c1 is the most common
but Queen c2 is the old kappa Blanco
move so it's got to be good night a6
very suspicious and c5 and remember what
I told you earlier in the lecture when
you see all these pawns here somebody's
gonna have an isolated queen pawn
somebody turned out it was black and
there's the isolated pawn so why could
have tried to win a pawn earlier but
White's King is on e 1 he doesn't want
to position open he doesn't want the D
file open he wants to closed up and he
wants to work on this pawn Oh for the
next sixty three moves or so
approximately and wow this is sort of
the starting position and as you can see
car bombs are already doing pretty
because he has a lot of guys blocking
the D pawn and when the D pawn is
blocked and it can't move then we can
win it later much later and Kasparov
wants to use the e4 square but Karpov is
defending that as well so Karpov was
ready for this Bishop e2 doesn't want to
play Bishop d3 and give the bishop away
or block his Queen and rook Queen b6 now
if black plays Knight to e4 that's very
risky because it loses immediately
therefore risky because I take
threatening your queen and if you take
what does white do yes Knight takes and
then White's a piece up with good
technique
okay so cus Prague doesn't want to play
94 eventually saw Queen b6 now maybe I
can play 94 castles 94 I didn't even
know you played that okay so did Karpov
take that knight on e4 anyone you can
guess know that I would call this the
isolated epon lecture it's not even
isolated now that rook on g8 it doesn't
want a pawn in front of it it wants to
attack that isolated pawn is blocking it
Queen c2 isolated pawn there forever
takes takes so by trading the Knights
it's hard for Chris morrow to put a
knight on e4 c4 and use his D pawn
effectively however Kasparov says trade
trade trade trade it's a draw how could
the guy beat me there's no pieces left
and the one piece that he has it's great
I got it pinned and attacked so I can
draw this Bishop e6 Kasparov was just
gonna chill out and say you can't beat
me
I'm too solid I got two bishops but he's
playing Karpov that was his only mistake
Queen c2 I'm pinning his knight
controlling f5 Karpov us to see my game
that hadn't happened
ciao Brooksie a queen bee one he doesn't
want the Queen on d2 he wants the rooks
to be on the D file and he wants his
queen to defend not only the b2 pawn but
control f5
I like playing queen bee one and queen
pawn openings then they can't attack my
queen rook c7 Kozlov wants to double on
the C file and now Knight takes c6
that's why this game is the white square
symphony now we're going to see white
taking over the white squares now when
you play Knight takes c6 and isolated
Queen pawn are you worried black is
going to take with a queen or the pawn
what do you worry about if you're Wyatt
in this position which room scares you a
little taking with a pawn because the
point is not isolated anymore thanks to
the Queen you're like I'll get great
isolated pawn not defended by the bishop
anymore now I'm gonna go win it Rick d1
Bishop f3 the Karpov was like wait a
minute if he takes with a pawn then I
could play Queen g6 Bishop d3 and I can
attack the King because there's no white
square defense of the King if it takes
with the Queen I'm gonna go win this guy
rook here Bishop here and there's no
bishop to defend it well tomorrow
there's an active player so he plays the
active move he got rid of his isolated D
pawn but he'll get it back he doesn't
want it back and now blacks King is
exposed because he's not defending the
white squares Bishop g4 attack putting
pressure on the pawn h3 getting left and
Karpov just moves around beautiful
doesn't really do very much but make
sure the pawns can't move and Bishop to
g6 and white actually has a very
interesting plan here he wants to give
black and isolated pawn again while he's
threatening made on the Kings side
and ephors the the key move of the game
so obviously Karpov wants to play queen
g6 but cartas was like no no no you're
not gonna do that
and if white trades Queens it's very
unlikely to win opposite colored bishops
even material so now he wants to give an
isolated pawn again and if black plays
d4 white can play e5 and then Queen e4
and the D pawn is hanging terrible so
once again he gets an isolated pawn and
we're back to square one and
unfortunately for black this King is
very safe that King is very suspicious
now most people like let's say Alex
Marla for example he's like rah or queen
h7 maid or something you know I have to
win now Karpov incredibly patient moves
his pieces around and around until
you're dizzy and then makes you later
and when you get better at chess like
Alex then you start to get more patient
and Karpov is building up in this
position is really ingenious this should
be one doesn't want the Queen attacking
the bishop now White has more squares
for his Queen to attack aged seven and
the bishop isn't getting hit anymore
Queen d2 who thinks white should trade
Queens I raised my hand and nobody else
did okay good Queen e5 rip d8 Queen f5
and Kasparov says pin getting made it as
bad so King g8 always repeat
every move okay always repeat as Alex
Marlar knows this ship f5 so now Karpov
wants to threaten me and then play
Bishop e6 check yeah this isn't so fun
for black always repeat and then g3 and
this is my favorite part of the game
when Karpov tucks his King away
he plays g3 taking away squares from the
dark squared bishop bishop can't go here
or here then he kicks the bishop out
very mean h4 that wasn't very nice and
what's the one white piece that hasn't
been checkmating black yet you the rook
on f1 where would you like your ruck be
six hmm
not like what Karpov did better but
you're good where else would you like
your rook put that white rook anywhere
you want AJ that's would require a
bughouse game I think I don't think that
work can get 2h a it okay Karpov decided
f3 was a good square why well it's good
square but also it stops black from
queening his isolated pawn if the rook
is on the third-ranked black doesn't
have any counter play so rook d1 rook d3
rook f3 now White has all his pieces
attacking I don't think blacks isolated
pawn is very helpful what is helpful is
White has more pawns around his King and
all the puns are on dark squares for
both sides on the Kings side so that
means this bishop can't go anywhere and
White's Bishop can go everywhere and and
the rule of thumb is you want your own
pawns on the opposite color of your
bishop and the same color of your
opponent's so that way your Bishop can
move around and your opponent's can't so
victory for Karpov here King e7
very suspicious queen h8 here comes the
past pawn but Karpov already stopped it
Queen CA surrounding the king
Ricky three check would be risky but
Ricky for check is not Ricky for check
queen C for check Bishop h7 what's the
threat why are you laughing they don't
know queen g8 mate with advantage not
only is this pawn isolated it stops the
black Bishop from defending blocking his
own Bishop terrible
what did black do in this position how
did he stop main it's Kasparov he
defends pretty well yes he didn't resign
you were thinking resigned terrible man
queen of seven queen c8 that's not
defending so well Rick f7 that's
defending better Queen e6 threatening
Queen e8 mate anyone
Queen d7 now you're defending better
how many more moves did say Karpov to
win this game seventy more hmm well
let's see I get pretty close to the end
no I was just kidding when I said he won
traded Queens and they agreed to a draw
no no traded Queens and black played d3
d2 and white resigned no also also not
good
Queen e5 threatening Queen B a check
with advantage yeah and we see that
White's King was safe blacks D pawn did
nothing and when Karpov wanted to play
rook e3 and e4 was played is play tricky
for he got his rook active his Queen and
Bishop and blacks D pawn never was there
was no danger for white that it was
queening because he blocked it and by
trading pieces and getting opposite
colored bishops unlike some other
grandmasters give you the wrong
information they don't work here
obviously colored bishops when there's
heavy pieces on the board means your
chances of evading attack are more
successful if the Queen's are off the
board it's almost certainly a draw
because it's hard to win with Queens on
the board whoever has the initiative
whoever's attacking the King they're
more likely to be successful with
opposite bishops this Bishop has a tough
time stopping that Bishop very tough and
who has the initiative thanks for asking
usually the person who has more pawns
around their King has a safer King so
White's King is very safe with the three
pawns black is much less safe with to
this point wasn't helpful at all it
didn't Queen it didn't
right in the Queen and it didn't defend
blacks King and when you look at games
like this that's surprising that
Kasparov is considered the greatest
player ever it seems like whites should
be the greatest player ever white really
positionally understood the game and
just totally dominated although if I
showed you games cuz Fabi Karpov you
would think the opposite
but Karpov was really good and still is
a strategical chess and getting really
small advantages and he did things
really great this game like g3 King G 2
and H for making his King perfectly safe
avoiding back ranked checks avoiding
tactics on f2 and taking all these
squares away from the black bishop so he
ended up here blocked by all his pawns
terrible and that's well I think one of
Karpov
greatest victories against Kasparov
because normally when you're playing a
tactician they're always getting counter
placed somehow that you overlooked you
know what I'm saying but somehow Karpov
sees the counter play snuffs it all out
and then black looks looks bad I think
he resigned here if you don't want to
resign you can try to make a move for
black good luck
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]